let's go to our caller from the 281 area
code who's calling today from 281
hi is that me yes it is
hey david um long time fan uh you're
actually the first person that got me
into podcasting so i just wanted to say
thank you
thank you love it um i had a question in
regards to
um the piece you had yesterday in
regards to
being a hobbyist um i was curious
on your thoughts on how to i guess make
the change from a hobbyist into sort of
a
of an activist um because it is very
hard to
get out of the mindset of just simply
looking at the
news or information that may suit you
and
applying that to actual change outside
of that
bubble that a person may put themselves
in well number one just asking the
question is important because a lot of
people who consume political news
as entertainment never ask this question
they never realize that just like
watching
msnbc doesn't really involve you
in politics and so i think there's a
couple different things number one
is i recommend everybody at the macro
level
don't just consume news and in fact i
have a very specific
and limited uh consumption of the
day-to-day news obviously i'm producing
a show and i'm reacting to what's
happening so
in in doing so i consume
information about what's going on but i
actually am focusing more and more of my
time on
understanding history and economics and
political philosophy etc so one
recommendation i always make is
if you want to take the news and
get more involved in making change learn
about other things that will
better allow you to interpret what's
going on and contextualize it in history
and within the context of different
political systems etc
but then beyond that um oftentimes what
allows people to go from being political
hobbyists to activists
is you can't be an activist on every
issue
and so figure out what's most important
to you
and try to activate there so if it's
climate
and local schools as an example figure
out how you can get involved
in wherever you live expanding
the infrastructure for transitioning to
clean energy as an example or you know
i'm just kind of riffing here but the
the idea being
you can't just say well i'm a
progressive activist and i'm going to
get involved everything i pay attention
to i'm now going to get involved and
it's just not possible there's too many
things in the world so
figure out what's most important to you
and then kind of work backwards and say
okay where can i most
most effectively and acutely
um affect some change in these
particular areas i think that that's
really the best start
got it so more narrow focusing and not
being so
broad we're thinking because i think
that's what comes overwhelming at times
is that
yeah a lot of people care about so many
different things that it
just becomes a too much at once focus on
your sphere of influence right
what can i impact what can i get
involved in right now and start there
you can still pay attention to
everything else that's going on
but try to narrow your focus of activism
right i mean i think right now i'm in
houston texas and um right now
what's with outstanding is what you've
also talked about how the
ever since the the data changed from the
cdc to
the trump administration it has not been
at all what the numbers have looked like
here yes and he's been
specifically i think which has passed a
large amount of cases so
it's very concerning i think that's one
of the main
points of activism that i'm aiming for
is really trying to
be have be more self-aware and spread
the actual truth with
what i can within my own abilities all
right
very good it sounds like you're you're
well on your way i appreciate the phone
call and please do check back in and let
us know
how things ended up going where you
ended up focusing